center of the u.s southern border
opening up to fully vaccinated travelers
yesterday putting additional strains on
security along the u.s mexico border
brandon judd is president of the
national border patrol council he joins
us now clearly this is a good thing
for commerce on texas border towns and
cities but there are questions that with
customs and border patrol under such
pressure already
uh because of so many different issues
as to whether or not you can adequately
vet the people who are coming across the
border now that it's reopened what are
your concerns
yeah the the chamber of commerce the
local businesses they've been asking
that the ports of entry be open for a
long time now and and i understand why
they their businesses have taken a
nosedive ever since the covet 19
pandemic and ever since we shut down the
the ports of entry to non-essential
travel but if you look at it from a law
enforcement standpoint and that's what i
have to look at it from
when you look at it from that aspect
this is not the right time to do this
simply because we are in the biggest
crisis border security crisis that we've
ever faced in the history of this
country and when you don't put policies
in place when you don't put programs or
operations in place that help us to
control the traffic that's coming into
the united states and pulling these
officers out of the field and putting
them back at the ports of entry
that's just going to open up gaps that's
going to allow cartels to exploit more
of our vulnerabilities and it's going to
allow more drugs to come into the united
states which we know are killing
children by the thousands
and so again from a law enforcement
standpoint this is not the right time to
do this so what's the answer to this man
because obviously you've got competing
interests here you've got the law
enforcement component of it but you also
have the commerce component of it you
have families who haven't seen each
other for 20 months who were so happy to
be reunited as people came across the
border yesterday is is there a way to
sort of balance both things or does it
have to be one or the other
no it doesn't have to be one or the
other we can actually secure the border
with the number of border patrol agents
that we have we can send the cpp
officers back to the ports of entry but
you have to have the proper policy if
you don't have policy in place that is
going to hold people in custody pending
their deportation or asylum hearings
we're going to open that floodgate it's
going to be that magnet that draws so
many people here so this administration
again what they what they refuse to
recognize what they've refused to assess
and address is the policy that they can
put in place that is going to help us
secure the border i don't need more
infrastructure more manpower more
technology i need policy president trump
proved that and of course as these
ground ports of entry have reopened
elsewhere along the border criminal
activity continues compiled just some
headlines from customs and border
protection media releases in the last
week take a look at this calexico agents
arrest sereno gang member over the
weekend multiple criminal migrants
arrested in the rio grande valley border
patrol agents kept a large group near
eagle pass multiple criminal migrants
arrested at the border hidalgo migrant
smuggler
endangers children at the arizona border
so so now we've we've as you point out
taken a lot of these agents out of the
field put them at the ports of entry and
meantime there's nothing that suggests
that cross-border criminal activity
outside of the ports of entry is slowing
what
down
just explained there if that doesn't
define crisis i don't know what does
everything that you said is what we're
dealing with on a daily basis and on top
of that you just talk with william
loginess about
people that are entering the country and
claiming to be 17 years old i can
personally tell you that when we take
somebody in custody the burden of proof
is on us to show that they are not who
they say that they are and if we can't
prove that then we have to treat them as
if they they are 17 when in reality
they're 24. i can tell you we see people
all the time who look if they look a day
younger than 21 i'd be surprised but we
have to treat them as if they are 17 if
they claim that if we cannot get the
cooperation from other countries or if
we don't have the time to do that so all
of these things when you stack all of
these things together you clearly see
that we just don't have control of the
border and this administration isn't
doing anything or putting programs in
place that is going to help us get
control of the border all right brandon
judd head of the national border patrol
council always good to be with you thank
you sir appreciate it
thank you john hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now